[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine weihnachtstage die
hat sich der murat gewünscht und ich
habe lange überlegt was für motiv ich
machen werde
einige weihnachten gibt es bereits auf
einem kanal da könnt ihr mal
vorbeischauen
heute gibt es eine torte die sieht
wirklich ziemlich cool ausfindig
aber sie ist in der herstellung gar
nicht so schwer also ihr können direkt
in einem tag super schaffen
und wenn ihr den teig und die creme auf
vortag schon zubereitet dann seid ihr
innerhalb von zwei bis drei stunden
fertig könnt die torte mitnehmen und
dann zum beispiel eure eltern oder die
familie am weihnachtstag überraschen
ich habe jetzt hier einen stiefel
gebacken hier oben schauen dann ein paar
süßigkeiten raus und diese kleinen
geschenk pakete im innern habe ich einen
lebkuchenteig haben eine vollmilch
garage und das ganze noch mit einer
rosmarin aprikosenmarmelade gefüllt und
nicht zuletzt zuerst einmal den teig her
für den teig verwende ich sechs eier
eine prise salz 200 gramm zucker 200
gramm butter milch 200 gramm
geschmolzene butter 250 gramm mehl 150
gramm gemahlene mandeln 40 gramm cacau
ein päckchen backpulver zehn gramm
lebkuchengewürz und 100 gramm
schokoladen streuseln also draußen wird
gerade noch der garten gemacht und
deswegen ist es hier auch ein bisschen
laut und rüttelt ich kann aber trotzdem
den teig in der zwischenzeit schon mal
machen
ich nehme jetzt erst die eier die kommen
in der rührschüssel gemeinsam mit dem
salz und zucker und dann ferro ich die
masse für etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
richtig schön cremig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sobald die eier zucker masse dann schaue
mich ist kommt jetzt die buttermilch
dazu hier könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
rotwein nehmen einen saft oder auch
mineralwasser dann füge ich noch die
flüssige butter dazu ungerührt die
zutaten ganz vorsichtig ein
und zum schluss kommen jetzt noch die
trockenen zutaten dazu und dann kann der
ganze teig kurz verrührt werden
natürlich den teig in eine backform hier
nämlich jetzt den bug rahmen und den
habe ich bereits auf 25 x 30 cm
eingestellt und so kann der teig direkt
gebacken werden und am besten macht ihr
es so dass ihr den teig am vortag schon
packt die ganache auch direkt herstellt
man kann nämlich beide super abkühlen
[Musik]
der tortenboden ist abgekühlt und auch
die garage ist natürlich kalt und hier
habe ich noch ein bisschen marmelade und
zwar nehme ich hier aprikosenmarmelade
und für feinere sich mit etwas rosmarin
also einfach den rosmarinzweig einlegen
und dann die marmelade erwärmen und so
nimmt sie einfach das schöne aroma von
rosmarin an gar nicht den tortenboden
herauslösen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich mir hier so eine grobe
schablone gemacht wie lege ich jetzt
hier drauf einfach hier drumherum
wegschneiden
jetzt kann ich den tortenboden nochmal
durchschneiden mit einer torten säge
[Musik]
an den boden vorsichtig weg heben und
gerne noch einmal durchschneiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das habe ich hier eine tortenplatte eine
richtig schöne stabile da kommt jetzt
ein bisschen war es von der gare straub
da wo der stiefel sein wird einfach als
kleber dann den ersten torten wurden
ganz vorsichtig drauf setzte und er so
ein bisschen nach unten denn oben kommt
er noch ein bisschen dick wo dran jetzt
mit der marmelade bestreichen riecht
schon richtig schön nach rosmarin und
aprikose
[Musik]
kommt hier ein bisschen von der gare
straub und wird dann auch schon
verstrichen
und so kann ich jetzt die komplette
torte füllen
[Musik]
und bei der creme habe ich mich für eine
voll menschen entschieden dass es eine
creme aus schokolade und sahne und da
gibt es bereits ein basic video dazu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und beim trockenen deckel habe ich jetzt
die mama darf der unterseite gestrichen
und kann den man hier vorsichtig
draufsetzen
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich hier noch ein
bisschen die reste und die kann ich
jetzt auch fein schneiden und dann hier
einfach oben draufsetzen oben so eine
kleine runde hinzubekommen und der rest
außenrum wird dann schön weggeschnitten
beim toppen deckel ist immer ein
bisschen schwierig weil der einfach so
locker sitzt da lässt sich gern mal die
obere schicht aber dann müsste einfach
ganz ganz vorsichtig streichen
ich habe auch ein kleines loch 1 gemacht
deshalb fand ich schlimm man kann selber
dazu machen hier ein bisschen und gerade
hier in der mitte ein bisschen und dann
passt das schon
und hier streiche ich jetzt die garage
am besten auf die unterseite
mit schneide ich hier den rand der torte
weg also ein bisschen rundlich und dann
könig die torte und kann sie danach mit
der ganz schön glatt streichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die reste diebe war ich auf daraus
mache ich nämlich gleich schöne kugeln
dabei
[Musik]
für die erste schicht danach habe ich
die garage noch mal ganz kurz erwärmt
damit sind bis zum streich wege ist denn
der kuchen die oberfläche die einfach so
zart dass ich sie ansonsten mitreißen
würde das heißt jetzt einfach den kuchen
schön bestreichen und die erste schicht
die bindet die kuchen krümmel so ein
bisschen
dann kommt der kuchen in den kühlschrank
und wir danach noch mal schön glatt
gestrichen
kann die zweite schicht aufgetragen
werden und jetzt gebe ich dem stiefel
auch so ein bisschen form das heißt hier
unten mache ich eventuell ein absatz
rein hier oben ein paar falten und dann
kann ich mir schon die deko auf
[Musik]
und für so rundungen da könnt ihr auch
ganz gut einen alten joghurt eimer zum
beispiel nehmen den auseinander
schneiden und da habt ihr einfach so
eine kunststoffschicht und mit diesem
kunststoffteil kann ich hier diese
rundungen immer schön glatt ziehen
als ich das einfach super flexibel an
die oberfläche anpasst und gerade hier
unten an der rundung ist es super
praktisch weil man wirklich diese folie
unten reinschieben kann und dann
wegzieht und dann entsteht da diese
perfekte runde
und so sieht der stiefel einfach nur mal
ein bisschen plastischer aus
hier oben und auch die sohle muss ich
jetzt nicht glatt machen
die sohle werde ich jetzt einfach gerade
wegschneiden und die sohle einmal glatt
ziehen und hier oben da kommen ja
sowieso später die deko teile rein das
heißt da muss ich mich gar nicht bemühen
was glatt zu streichen tapezieren tele
roten fondant den habe ich jetzt hier
einfach auch einmal ganz praktischer ist
und den habe ich bereits weit geknetet
und kann ihn jetzt auf etwas becker
stärker ausrollen unternehmen die auch
am besten bäcker stärker das ist nämlich
eine reine kartoffelstärke und die klub
nicht die klebt nicht gut zu gehen da
nicht so gut und speisestärke ist da
auch nicht gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das hole ich die decke hier ein bisschen
aufwand die torte nehmen und weil jetzt
die oberfläche ein bisschen trocken ist
die garage ist natürlich fest geworden
nämlich etwas back grenzkrieg und dann
hält davon dann richtig schön ohne eben
bläschen zu werfen
jetzt brauche ich dich darüber legen
dann mit den händen schön glatt
streichen
gerade hier bei den falken ist dann ganz
wichtig dass man da ganz vorsichtig ist
und hier oben möchte ich jetzt ein paar
falten rein machen damit der stiefel
plastischer aussieht
[Musik]
da oben ist auch nicht schlimm wenn eine
kleine lücke bleibt denn da kommen ja
sowieso die deko elemente rein
[Musik]
und die reste verpacke ich luftig der
tüte haben sie wieder zurück in den
eimer packen und kann sie dann beim
nächsten mal wieder weiter verwenden
nämlich hier mein modell werkzeug
ihr könnt natürlich auch einfach die
finger nehmen oder einen löffel zum
beispiel ganz vorsichtig sein und jetzt
einfach so ein bisschen noch die falten
nachziehen so bekommt der stiefel noch
ein bisschen mehr struktur
und die becker steige die lässt sich
dann ganz einfach mit dem pinsel wieder
entfernen sind auch in echt großer
vorteil
der stiefel ist jetzt im allgemeinen
eigentlich schon mal fertig und jetzt
kommt ihr die feinde deko das heißt bis
dahin ist es wirklich gar nicht so viel
arbeit
jetzt könnt euch bei der deko austoben
ich habe hier ein bisschen schwarze
modell ihr schokolade die hat 25 prozent
echte schokolade und riecht auch nach
weißer schokolade und die eignet sich
ganz gut zu modellieren die rolle ich
jetzt auch auf laptops becker stärke aus
und damit mache ich dann den gürtel
und jetzt nimmt die entweder eine pizza
und ein messer ich nehme dir
eingesickert so kann ich direkt den
streifen schön ausschneiden in der
gewünschten breite
[Musik]
dann nehme ich mir zwei förmchen können
dann natürlich auch ohne förmchen machen
jetzt einfach schauen dass das förmchen
und witzigen größer ist als der gürtel
und dann noch ein kleineres förmchen und
damit kann ich dann hier noch ein
viereck ausstechen für die
gürtelschnalle das gar nicht die
rückseite wird etwas essbarem kuba
bestreiten
[Musik]
und habe ich jetzt die schnelle dann
nehme ich jetzt den mittleren teil raus
[Musik]
jetzt bekommt die schnelle noch ein
bisschen glanz und darf er nämlich
einfach metallic screen kupfer
[Musik]
die schnelle lassen jetzt so erstmal
trockenen die mache ich dann zum schluss
dran und diesen part denen was ich jetzt
auch ganz kurz hier aus herten
den brauchen wir nämlich auch später
noch liegen nämlich jetzt noch einen
ganz kleinen rest von der schwarzen
modelle schokolade und vorne einen stift
das ist dann der stift für die schnelle
und den braucht jetzt nicht bespielt
wird wieder einfach hier auf
küchenpapier und einfach so ein bisschen
hin und her rollen
da reicht die frage auf jeden fall noch
aus
[Musik]
während die deko teile hier nur fest
werden kann ich schon mal die übrige
deko machen und dafür brauche ich weißen
von und den weißen von dort verkehrt ich
jetzt mit ein bisschen zellulose pulver
und der sorgt dafür dass der vom doch
ein bisschen aushärtet zellulose kennt
man auch aus blüten passte da steckt
nämlich drin
ihr könnt doch einfach von dort mit
blüten passte verkneten das geht auch
gut oder eben so wenn man das nicht
macht man ist davon doch einfach sehr
weich und ich möchte gleich dass dieser
weise von dort so ein bisschen über die
torte hinausragt und deswegen gesagt
stabil werden und fest werden
ansonsten könnte das auch weglassen das
pulver und den von der einfach nur
direkt auf die torte legen
das merkt man auch gleich das fenster
wird und dann wieder auf biker stärker
ausfallen
jetzt möchte ich dass der stiefel
schafft etwa 4 cm breit wird also
schneide ich jetzt ein weißes band zu
was 8 cm hat damit es einmal umschlagen
kann
[Musik]
und damit er jetzt hier nicht einknickt
kompliziert einfach als verstärkung ein
bisschen küchenrolle rein alufolie wird
auch gehen einfach irgendwas die form
stabil hält
[Musik]
und dann einfach die decke stecke vorne
dran stellen oder was anderes damit
nicht wegrutscht so kann der weiße
partien fest werden
jetzt kümmere ich mich schon mal um die
schuhsohle solltet ihr das modell ihr
schokolade in schwarzen auf 5 mm breiter
aus das geht am besten mit teig hölzern
und jetzt nämlich eine struktur roller
das wird jetzt nämlich die schuhsohle
das gut überlegen welche richtung doch
die richtung bestimmt jetzt rolle ich
hier einmal drüber damit die schuhsohle
strukturiert ist
sieht man jetzt hier auch ganz gut jetzt
habe ich hier eine schablone angefertigt
ich habe einfach ein papier hingelegt an
die sohle und habe mitten im
lebensmittel stift ausgezeichnet und
hier ausgeschnitten und die schuhsohle
wird jetzt hier auch ausgeschnitten und
dann kann ich sie dran kleben
[Musik]
nachdem dran halten dann einfach noch
dran kleben
[Musik]
und mache ich jetzt noch mal separat der
sohle und dann mache ich ja als
abschluss noch ein schönes band aus
[Musik]
und ist nämlich nicht nur eine loch
thüle einfach direkt auf den finger und
macht so ein paar nieten noch ein
[Musik]
die lasche schneide ich jetzt hier und
nicht so
[Musik]
die lasche runde jetzt hinten ab und
nehme dann mit einem loch thüle um peter
löscher einzubauen
deshalb ist hier ein bisschen gekürzt
und jetzt lege ich die lasche über die
schnelle drüber und aus dem ersten loch
kommt dann noch der kleine stifte
[Musik]
jetzt ist der stiefel im prinzip fast
fertig jetzt wird nur noch das kickboxen
gemacht dafür nämlich jetzt puderzucker
und wasser und kann dann das clipboard
damit bestreichen
ihr könnt natürlich auch deutschland
nehmen aber so geht es einfacher
[Musik]
jetzt einfach mit einer palette
auftragen
[Musik]
kommen dann noch die schneeflocken drauf
die habe ich einfach aus dem restlichen
weißen von dor ausgestochen
wir sind trocknen lassen und wenn ihr
möchtet dass die auch noch schön
glitzern
dann nehmt einfach ein bisschen
silbermetallic farbe
[Musik]
und auch auf die torte gibt jetzt ein
bisschen silbernen glitzer schnee dann
klebt das richtig schön wie schnell das
auf skateboard getourt
[Musik]
wir nehmen das könnt ihr noch eine frohe
weihnachtsbotschaft auf die torte
schreiben dafür erstelle ich jetzt ein
kleines schild ich nehme jetzt einfach
die übrig gebliebene von landmasse und
die modelle schokolade und rolle sie auf
3 mm stärke aus dann stellte ich zwei
quadrate aus und es eine quadrat es
etwas kleiner als das andere
[Musik]
der weiße rahmen wird jetzt mit etwas
metallic spray besprüht und dann werden
beide teile zusammengesetzt
[Musik]
jetzt vermisse ich etwas weiße pulver
farbe mit wasser hier könnt ihr
natürlich auch alkohol verwenden und
können dann die botschaft mit einem
pinsel draufschreiben und jetzt wird die
torte fertig dekoriert ich habe hier
noch so kleine schokoladentäfelchen die
süß als geschenk verpackt sind
jetzt lege ich hier alles so hin als
wird es einfach aus diesem stiefel
herausfallen zuckerstangen habe ich hier
noch ich habe die werde aber ein
bisschen kürzen oder von kleiner macken
zimtsterne habe ich hier noch und da
könnt ihr jetzt wirklich den stiefel
fertig dekorieren wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
frank du darfst probieren ich deutscher
bin nun aber murat ist nicht da er ist
gegangen herzlich die torte gewöhnt
schon jetzt sicher nicht da ich es aber
nicht so wie man dass ich das ganze
stückchen innerhalb von fünf sekunden
aus ja ich weiß da ist es klar dass
müsse es sein das ist so bist du ins
auto bringen ja eigentlich nicht aber
mit der ballade ist das bild oder
schmeckt man den rosmarin raus nicht
gern hab ich bestimmt ein tolles aroma
bestimmt naja jedenfalls habe ich hier
noch die resteverwertung und zwar habe
ich dafür einfach die kuchen reste
genommen die marmelade noch verwendet
habe die garage mit rein und alles schön
verknetet und wenn die masse damen zu
feucht ist dann können wir einfach noch
ein bisschen kekse dazugeben und wenn
sie zu trocken ist einfach nur bisschen
flüssigkeit um zum beispiel können
nämlich rumkugeln machen und dann
einfach in einer mischung aus mandeln
kakao und zimt wälzen machst du dir auch
probieren
ich probierte auch musterwohnung gemacht
nämlich zone ist schon lebkuchen gesetzt
ich spreche erst zu ende und probiert
[Gelächter]
falls ihr die torte nämlich nach machen
wollt könnt ihr einfach auf sex - blog
de vorbeischauen
ich denke dass sich jeder über diese
weihnachtskarte freuen würde und jetzt
wünschen wir euch allen frohe
weihnachten
frage das war unser weihnachts verstehen
was ja und johan 2
sie können also viel spaß bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]